vous retrouve même si vous n'êtes pas à
l'image dans un coup de force contre une
célèbre épicerie de luxe à paris au gd
vous y étiez oui aux cris de les fauchés
chez fauchon
[Musique]
plus d'une centaine de jeunes chômeurs
et des membres des jeunesses communistes
ont occupé samedi en début d'après-midi
la célèbre épicerie de luxe fauchon
place de la madeleine
après s'être servis dans le magasin les
jeunes ont présenté une vendeuse des
bons d'achats d'actifs j'étais dans
l'image
j'ai occupé ces magasins où on peut
trouver des bouteilles de digestif
1200000 lagaf' il y a dans ce pays les
gens qui n'ont rien absolument rien pour
vivre pour passer les fêtes et d'autres
qui ont toujours au poids grandissant
des deux
un luxe insolent les manifestants ont
été délogés par la police violemment
selon as we violemment on a pris des
coups de matraque des magasins tout
rentrait dans l'ordre il m'a semblé
reconnaître jacques perreux le leader
des jeunes communistes de l'époque et et
vous même âge l'âge vous allez je crois
je suis avec mes copains on était
ensemble et je les ai je les ai reconnus
donc devait être derrière avec eux mais
je m'en souviens parfaitement ont
dénoncé effectivement cette société à
deux vitesses et je me demande si c'est
pas moi qui tourne le dos je vois qu'ils
olivier marché avec qui je suis là qui
est la première
et on découvre ensemble d'ailleurs et
donc quand on a ont dénoncé donc
ses magasins pour les riches et en même
temps une société du chômage qui était
en train de grandir et c'était
insupportable ont dénoncé les emprunts
giscard qui avaient été mises en place
ou en gros en plus quand on était riche
on pouvait emprunter avec des intérêts
derrière qui nous faisait gagner de
l'argent on a été
évacuée manu militari par les crs on a
pris des coups sur la tête et à la
sortie de ce magasin j'ai été embarqué
je me suis retrouvé dans un commissariat
où j'ai été mis nu pour
certainement pour m'humilier ils m'ont
fait mettre à poil voilà ils m'ont
laissé à poil comme ça pendant un long
moment
pour puis après ils m'ont demandé de me
rhabiller et puis dans la nuit j'ai été
j'ai été libéré
je vois là je m'en souviens ça m'a
marqué
[Musique]